based on votes of moviegoers all over
the nature most popular actor of the
game
please to make your acquaintance man
The Rock was an icon he was by far the
biggest star in Hollywood not only did
women say that's the man I want to marry
many men said that's the man I'd like to
be he had more than one world he had the
studio world he had this gay world if
the truth
that would have been the end of his
career
oh you hiding in closets isn't going to
cure you
rock is the last of those manufactured
Stars where every aspect of what we
think to be their private life has been
built by other people you are Divine I
know but I'm in training
we were ordered never to have our
picture taken together because somebody
would know
that we were gay
people loved him he was just a decent
wonderful guy
let me begin with the latest figures
from Los Angeles County today they show
56 new cases of AIDS the public started
seeing a major decline in his appearance
it was so much thinner and didn't look
like he felt good that's when even we
thought it was AIDS actor Rock Hudson
has acquired immune deficiency syndrome
it was everything kind of wrapped up in
one it was Hollywood and the closet and
the fact that rock had lived his life
not able to express who he was
and it had come to that
when he died longtime friend Elizabeth
Taylor prayed that he had not died in
vain he was seen as the All-American boy
and the All-American boy gets AIDS it's
really changed a lot of people's
attitudes he pretty much did change the
course of history around AIDS he didn't
intentionally do it but there was no
other star that made that kind of impact
before it hasn't been one since really
[Music]
foreign